I want to talk
I've been thinking about you and me not
how this is going to end about who will
end up killing who perhaps you'll kill
me perhaps I'll kill you you know that
don't you
tell me what I'm doing here you're going
man
where is he why aren't you
all it takes is one bad day
hey youtubers is charlie so Batman
Killing Joke we finally have an official
trailer it's one of the first if not the
actual first r-rated animated DC movie
you've probably heard about the story if
you haven't read it it's Alan Moore's
take on the psychology of the Joker like
he really tries to get into the Joker's
head so most Batman's stories view the
Joker through the lens of the Batman
through other characters this is more of
a direct take on the Joker but I like
the way the trailer says we need to talk
about us we need to have that
relationship talk one of us is going to
wind up killing the other and if you're
wondering why it took so long to get an
animated DC movie well part of the
problem is is that the animated movies
the audience for that is mostly younger
children so obviously it's going to be
done more on the tone of Batman the
Animated Series violence without a lot
of blood mark hamill actually explained
when they were making the original
batman the animated series there were a
lot of things they just couldn't do
because it was being viewed by children
in fact I think I watched a lot of them
after school in the afternoon Fox had
this like afternoon block of animated
programming where they would air new
episodes and even though recently
r-rated superhero movies are really
invoke Deadpool really went a long way
towards making people ready for more
r-rated takes on superheroes without
being more graphic than it needed to be
you know Deadpool was like just the
right amount of r-rated craziness for
Deadpool's character but what about
Batman though I mean Batman V Superman
is a pretty dark take on those
characters but an animated movie is just
like a whole other level the reason the
killing joke animated movie is rated R
is because they wanted to honor the
comic book as much as possible and I
wouldn't say it's a shot-for-shot remake
of the comic book but they are doing the
comic book story so most of the iconic
panels that you see in the comic book
will show up in the movie but it's not
going to be like a 10 hour movie so
there's going to be some stuff that's
gonna have to brush over it's not like
they just like copy and pasted the
panels from the comic book to the screen
but the really big selling you know shut
up and take my money selling points are
that they got Kevin Conroy and Mark
Hamill to come back to do their take on
the characters the animation style looks
a little more unique just that you see
some like the hard lines you can tell
this is going to be a much darker take
on Batman and I think they wanted the
animation to reflect that the other
really cool thing about this story is
that it also addresses the origin story
of the Joker Alan Moore's version of the
origin story took inspiration from a 19
51 story called the man behind the Red
Hood so he's pulling from a lot of
Batman cannon Alan Moore you know one of
the greatest comic book writers of all
time even though he's pretty mercurial
and he's largely distance himself from
mainstream comics now is always funny
when really great writers call their old
work trash but is so much better than
other stories that you can't understand
why they don't like their own work so
much I think that probably has something
to do with the self-loathing that people
feel like no matter how good you do you
still think that you're garbage but when
people talk about the story The Killing
Joke story they talk about it more as a
joker story than a Batman story it's
like the best Joker story of all time
great Batman soirée definitely top five
Batman story but number one joker story
so the real star of this is not kevin
conroy as Batman who's probably one of
the best Batman of all time it's mark
hamill's Joker in one of my favorite
parts of this trailer is when he goes
into the amusement park he's walking up
to the Joker they're really they're
doing this panel right here from the
comic but this is really awesome real
life origin story for how Bill Finger
came up with the idea for the Joker most
people know him as being based on the
man who laughs that silent film
character but there was this clown
picture on a ride from Coney Island that
he would walk around like he had a
picture of it that he would walk around
with it in his wallet and even I think
it was like carmine infantino who's
another famous comic book crater he's
one of those guys that created a lot of
the characters that they're using on the
flash TV show right now he said that
Bill Finger would walk around with the
picture from that Joker ride at Coney
Island in his wallet and that was also
part of the inspiration for the look of
the Joker that in the man who laughs it
was kind of a combination of those
things that if you played the arkham
game whenever you first meet the orical
Barbara Gordon character in person it
flashes back to that so they find a way
to work aspects of The Killing Joke
story into a lot of other Batman's
stories cartoons video games so you've
probably seen a version of this most
people who have never read the actual
story just know it as the story where
Barbara Gordon got shot by the Joker and
wasn't able to walk anymore so
eventually she became the Oracle
character but she doesn't become the
Oracle character to way later in the
comics The Killing Joke story really
just brought her to the edge of death
and other writers came on later into the
Oracle stuff but if you haven't read it
now is the good time to run out read the
comic they're not releasing the actual
movie you won't be able to buy it like
you'll be able to say shut up and take
my money
till around comic-con later this year in
July so late July is when the actual
movie is dropping here's my big question
for you guys let me know in the comments
even if you haven't read The Killing
Joke story what do you think about the
idea of r-rated DC films in general and
then what do you think about the idea of
animated r-rated films do you think it's
crazy are you really excited about it
I'm actually really excited I definitely
think there's an audience for it but
don't don't expect all their films to
start going super hardcore now if you
see a little boy running around on the
street in a batman shirt he's the
audience for these animated films so
don't expect too many are rated stories
coming in related comic book news I'm
catching up on my agents of shield stuff
so they'll be an agent of shield video
later tonight for this week's episode
there's a new episode of legends of
tomorrow that video will post tomorrow
haha always liked the way I said that
legends of tomorrow posting tomorrow and
they'll be soon new captain america
civil war maybe soon new spider-man
maybe some new Suicide Squad too there's
a little bit of Suicide Squad stuff
that's been happening lately while you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for last night's episode
of arrow they just debuted a big
character that's going to be a big deal
on season five you can click here for my
spider-man civil war video thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight